david souter und das hier ist ein alpaka
was ich mal von einer detailgetreuen
iran nicht wie sich die bedingungen für
herzliche willkommen heutigen video ich
habe euch bei twitter gedanken sollten
wir wieder irgendwelche video zu wenden
und da reagiert jetzt braucht da werden
wir nie zugewendet die bahn vielleicht
vor 40 jahren irgendwann wallin
ich werde diesen koffer niemals zu
bekommen ich habe wieder gebraucht wird
einfach nur hashtag locker reagiert und
ich sagte dann dass wirklich werde ich
wohl nicht sagen dumme video einzelnen
vernünftige video vom wir sind jetzt
dran war leider nicht der fall ist
welche gebracht warum kopf nicht so geht
werde diesen koffer niemals zu bekommen
will nun kanal und verlange riesiger
teddybär drin liegt aber wir machen
weiter mit der nächsten einblendung nach
dem ansehen des videos tue ich mir jetzt
so zwei fragen auf und zwar erstens was
ist mit dem jungen am ende dort und
weisen kann es sein dass jeder irgendwie
gerade den urlaub mit der vorherigen
einwendung hatten medien koffer gepackt
und bei eine familie im auto heraus und
oder und in deutschland vier tagen
durchgängig am regler draußen
ok freunde ich glaube bis feiern und
sich wieder so ein bisschen im niveau
und zwar werden bei sport 1 sendung
geschickt und ich glaube das ist die
platine spongebob vorher irgendwie laut
wicke gemacht und jetzt macht das niveau
wurde doch nicht gesteigert
[Musik]
danke danke dass du ihr ein video von
einer schwäche ins heim gesteckt hat ihr
jetzt mal eine video für euch von meinem
hacker
[Musik]
das kann ich mal stehen alltag auf dem
acker einfach locker drauf steht aber
nicht über der erich das bekommen
zusammen mit noch wie tausend andere
pakete mit eingeschränkten viele
zuschauer haben mich dort gefragt ob ich
mich ein video das sie machen kann
da habe ich gefragt nicht leicht machen
kann wie lange gefackelt zu machen kam
durch die ganzen geschenke mal auf
fakten und da muss ganz ehrlich sagen ja
nicht mal beim thema und war wollte ich
entweder heute abend auch instagram
leisten machen also hier in programmen
luca oder halt morgen und welche
geschenke auspacken
er läuft in den klassenraum
ich versuche das ganze mal nachzustellen
[Musik]
also an der stelle muss ich wirklich
sagen
das beeindruckt mich wirklich mit einem
kaninchen springen kann musste die muss
ich so jetzt gar nicht danke für die
erste talent wurde einwendung in die
verfolger reagieren sie hat da glaube
ich dass sie trete von allen walker auf
dem keyboard gespielt übrigens viel wie
dabei also ich habe früher mal jahre
gespielt und jetzt habe ich alles
fertigbringt wieder bock drauf habe ja
ich habe respekt vor leuten die
instrumente spielen können und so weiter
und so fort also auf jeden fall schauen
dich du bist mir gut und wenn ihr
irgendwelche die man besser nicht in die
kommentare
da muss ich wirklich sagen weil ich sehr
froh dass unserer schule früher mit dem
song gehandelt oder bei dürfte jeder
einfach alles machen was er heute ich
meine sie eigentlich jedem selbst
überlassen wie er sich ansieht und was
der selber isst und trinkt und diese
schule mitbringt und kein hitzefrei ist
halt beschützen aber hat mich zum
beispiel auch die bauern früher immer
gesagt man sich erst befreit in den
kältesten räumen der schule
überdurchschnittliche temperaturen
liegen die kelten waren im dritten täter
gestoppt da war immer an - 1000 grad und
hinrich in süßigkeiten und süßen
getränken kann ich nur sagen trinkt mein
leben lang eigentlich immer nur baba und
habe auch in der schule eigentlich immer
vernünftige sachen gegessen und so aber
dass wir trotzdem und so keine ahnung
meiner meinung nach solider anti mafia
will schwindlig korrekt bruder freute
mich auf jeden fall dass die der lukas
nach geschmeckt hat mottaki der egal
denn hab ich dich irgendwie --der
nachgefragtes oder grill
denn es gibt wirklich sehr großen
unterschied für tag welche die video
allerdings auch beenden beide nach unten
mit wird das tut mir leid dass die
heutige lücke reagieren folge jetzt
nicht irgendwie fünf minuten gingen oder
sarah oben wird von klare ganz viele
leute bei uns vom fischer verlag
geplanten buch und so weiter
bevor ich jetzt zu früh froidevaux wird
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr dieses jahres
kommen
das was wir gerade schreiben werden die
kleinkrafträder ein bisschen bis ein
bisschen kindheit geschichten von mir
mit kinderbildern sein und ist in rijeka
sowie den menschen geworden
der jetzt gerade bin und das kommt
wahrscheinlich erst in vielen monaten
raus oder so wer während der sehr ihr
mit beschäftigen gerade nur die waren
halt leider gerade oben auf mich und ich
nehme gerade mein wir ja auch also endet
wegen ich hoffe trotzdem gefallen haben
hat sie oben einen smiley eingebildeten
könnte meinen carla bruni oder oben auch
meinen job eingeblendet und hier unten
alle video verlegt